(soft music)
- At approximately 35
weeks into your pregnancy,
your provider will have you
take a Group B Streptococcus
or GBS test.
Let's talk about what GBS is
and why this test is so
important for a healthy birth.
GBS is a type of bacteria
that can live normally
in a woman's genital or urinary tract
and it's considered a
normal type of bacteria.
It is not a sexually-transmitted disease
and no treatment is indicated
for women who have the bacteria.
However, during delivery,
when a baby is moving
along the birth canal,
it can be exposed to GBS
and unfortunately can become very sick.
Before routine testing for GBS,
about 1.7 babies out of 1,000 births
will become seriously
infected after delivery.
Because of this,
we now routinely test women
to see if they carry GBS
in their genitourinary tract
reducing the incidence
of serious infections
to just 0.22 cases per 1,000 births.
Your provider may either
give you instructions
for doing the swab
yourself in the bathroom
during your prenatal visit
or may collect the swab
for you during the visit.
If you have a strong preference
for one option or the other,
please talk with your provider
to let him or her know.
This is the swab
and it's swept around
the outside of the vagina
down the perineum and
into the rectum briefly.
Your provider will contact you
with the results of your test.
If you do carry the bacteria,
you're given antibiotics
through an IV during labor
to prevent transmission to the baby
while it's traveling
through the birth canal.
If you've had a urinary tract
infection during pregnancy
that was due to GBS bacteria,
you don't need a swab
because you're already
known to have the bacteria
and you'll be given antibiotics
during labor as well.
Antibiotics are safe for
pregnancy and for breastfeeding.
If you have a known allergy to penicillin,
it's important to let your provider know
when the GBS swab is being collected
as special testing will be done
to identify the best alternate
antibiotic to use instead.
GBS testing is just one of the many ways
that we work to prevent
problems before they occur
protecting you and your baby
during your labor and delivery experience.
(soft music)